[Musique]
c'est le premier vice président du
département délégué aux affaires
agricoles en personne qui pose ce
premier tuyau départ de la nouvelle
opération d'extension des périmètres
irrigués du sud faire une extension du
périmètre irrigué sur le territoire de
petites îles et sur le canton 22
377 hectares ce n'est pas rien des
secteurs aujourd'hui on fait que de la
canne à sucre on va pouvoir faire de la
diversification agricole est aussi
augmenté l'europe le rendement à
l'hectare de cannes donc pour nos
agriculteurs c'est vraiment une
excellente nouvelle de faire arriver
l'eau sur ce secteur de montvert les
hauts et hans leo et pis pour la commune
de petite île c'est aussi l'apport en
eau brute de la saphir à travers cet
ouvrage du département vers notre unité
de potabilisation qui est en cours de
construction juste à côté on va aussi à
travers cette opération donc garantir la
desserte en eau de la commune de petite
île et de l'ensemble de ses administrés
et abonnés augmenter les surfaces
agricoles et les productions végétales
et animales c'est la trajectoire
inscrite dans le plan a grippé y 2030
qui vise à atteindre l'autonomie
alimentaire pour le sud de l'île ce sera
d'ici 2023 près de 1500 hectares
supplémentaires qui seront irrigués et
on veut apporter une réponse pérenne
pour ces agriculteurs qui sont motivés à
pour atteindre cet objectif final de de
souveraineté agricole à la réunion mais
l'eau c'est la vie et le heat a
absolument nécessaire et le département
s'emploie actuellement à faire à mettre
tout en oeuvre pour pouvoir faire en
sorte que ces agriculteurs puissent
bénéficier de cette ressource le
transfert d eau pour l'irrigation
continue son déploiement après l'ouest
et le sud c'est le nord et l'est qui
travaille également sur leurs grands
projets de transfert baptisée projet
mais rennes
[Musique]